this video is brought to you by VIN
Cheryl watches click the link below to
check out their biggest sale of the year
hey wise crack Jared here you may have
noticed a trend lately it seems like
every day some company announces a new
cloud or platform service for people to
download a few months ago Google
announced its Google stadia game
streaming platform which will include
YouTube integration and allow gamers to
play games from most any screen with an
internet connection the announcement was
met with some excitement from big game
developers looking for new distribution
deals and a lot of skepticism from
gamers prompting eye rolls and also some
questions like what games will be
available will people actually own their
games or will everything be
subscription-based how will everyone's
data be used and what will happen when
Google takes on Sony Nintendo Microsoft
and popular PC gaming platforms like
Steam it's not just a question of gaming
platforms that have people asking
questions though platforms and
subscription models are spreading like
the plague CBS has successfully forced
nerds into submission by requiring them
to pay $5.99 a month for the privilege
of watching Star Trek on their
all-access platform Apple recently
announced that devices will be taking a
backseat to game news and video
subscriptions on a new Apple platform
and Disney who already owns a lot of
things is launching Disney Plus which
will ask us to pay another subscription
to watch things that were once available
on Netflix and a slate of new Marvel
shows and NBC has yet to launch their
own streaming service which will again
steal the office from Netflix no God
please no no no no people seem annoyed
that these services are just another
thing hankering to siphon a few bucks a
month out of their pockets but is there
a deeper problem here and is that
problem platforms themselves maybe maybe
not but for better or worse platforms
are changing our entire economic system
and I'm here to talk about how why and
what it all means
so welcome most wisecrack edition on the
platform economy but before we get into
it I want to give a shout out to this
week's sponsor Finn Sherrill watches and
Sherrill makes high quality watches for
a fraction of the price
other luxury brands by cutting out the
middleman and delivering it straight to
you one of my favorite things about
wearing up in Cheryl watch is how it
keeps me on task it's super easy to get
pulled into a black hole of
notifications on my phone whenever I
check the time but wearing a watch
allows me to avoid being constantly
distracted it also looks really nice so
I can wear it on regular workdays or for
something more elegant right now than
cher was celebrating their fifth year in
business and saying thank you just
wasn't enough
so they decided to run their biggest
sale of the year for a limited time only
everything on their site is on sale even
their all-new collection no exclusions
each watch has its own unique look and
is always high-quality right now I'm
wearing the chrono s in black it's solid
scratch resistant and even though it's
dark it's completely visible at night
then cheryl has received over 16,000
five-star reviews so step up your style
game and get your venero watch today
their anniversary sale can get you up to
25% off your entire purchase so click
the link below to take advantage of this
insane sale and now back to the show
today we're surrounded by platforms a
platform is a website or application
that brings two or more sides of a
market together that is a digital space
where people who need a service can find
and pay for that service the earliest
example is probably eBay the site
originally launched as auction web in
1995 and created a platform for someone
who wants to sell their autographed
marky-mark underwear to an eager buyer
this is real by the way
after eBay success other companies
started springing up with similar
business models Amazon originally
connected book publishers with readers
remember when Amazon only sold books
Ticketmaster created an online space for
venues to sell tickets and soon there
were platforms for everything now uber
connects drivers with passengers Airbnb
Connex spare rooms with travellers and
Spotify connects listeners with music
but let's back up from it how did we
even get here once upon a time before
free markets economies were regionally
based and self contained according to
political economist Karl Polanyi there
were three general types of economic
systems reciprocity where goods are
exchanged as gifts between communities
for instance a tribe gives another tribe
a cow and eventually gets one back later
on in the year
householding in which families produce
food and goods and tools for their own
use and consumption and redistribution
we're a tribal leader or feudal lord
controls all the resources and then
redistributes them to members of their
society now remember this one we're
gonna come back to it later in all of
these survival wasn't really based on
how efficient production was sure a crop
may not grow well year-over-year but
there were contingency plans such as
storing crops or minimal exchange on
simple markets like bartering with your
neighbor for what you need but
eventually capitalism happened and the
rules changed people became increasingly
separated from the things they needed to
survive turning to the market to get
things like food water and shelter and
selling their skills to whoever would
pay by the late 1700s industry was
booming and manufacturing began to take
over Europe in 1776 Scottish economist
Adam Smith published an inquiry into the
nature and causes of the wealth of
nations outlining the benefits of
efficient production and singing praises
about how dope the free market is and
people liked his theories the market
eventually expanded as standards of
living began to change from bare
essentials like food and clothes to
luxury items but having so many
different sellers selling all these
things led to competitive pressures if
your goods were too expensive no one
would buy them so businesses started
lowering production cost so they could
sell their items for less while still
maintaining enough profits businesses
have been lowering production costs ever
since primarily by turning to technology
and lowering labour costs which was easy
to do if you were in manufacturing and
technology got better and better and you
could pay less and less for labour
it started with assembly lines which
provided companies with cheaper labor
that didn't need to be trained in any
special skills instead of learning how
to put a whole car together a worker
just had to learn how to put one piece
of the car in one place eventually a
large business realized that robots
could do that instead of people and
since you don't have to pay robots
salaries soon some of these places
barely had any employees at all but
there were still businesses that
couldn't really use assembly lines or
robots to cut as many costs places like
grocery stores or taxi companies or
movie theaters until the internet came
around
stores and service providers suddenly
had to compete with websites where you
can get the same product or service
mailed to you directly from the
distributor with the click of a button
or find a room in someone's house to
sleep in instead of booking a hotel room
the owners of these new websites these
platforms don't need to pay any labor
costs because people doing the buying
and selling are doing it for them in
other words uber isn't a taxi company
it's a technology company that pairs an
independently contracted driver with you
the consumer but even those
independently contracted drivers are a
liability as the company moves towards
driverless vehicles ok so now we
understand how platforms happened but
why are they making people so uneasy
well it might be because people are
losing their sense of autonomy and
ownership you know I asked you to
remember karl polanyi's redistribution
where one person controls and
redistributes all the resources like a
feudal lord well it's because more and
more the way platforms operate feels
very similar to that kind of economy
tech companies own assets and distribute
them to us and as a result some of
argued a new kind of feudalism has
emerged one where companies are like
Lords and subscribers are like serfs
paying rent to access some stuff so if
this is the case will we all be
indentured to our platforms in his 2016
article yevgenii morsov describes the
steady march of Google and Facebook
towards feudal ownership over greater
proportions of the economy by destroying
all competition and making the world
dependent on their platforms more zob
suggests these neo feudal lords will
increase their control over how economic
resources are accessed political
theorist Nick Cernik goes as far as
saying that these big companies are
becoming owners of the infrastructure of
society ending private property for the
masses and having everything provided as
a service by quasi monopolistic firms we
don't own stuff anymore companies
basically lease everything to us and at
the moment these companies are all
fighting with each other over who gets
to provide us with access to stuff that
they control instead of owning cars
people are taking rideshares with
changing prices generated by algorithms
instead of owning CDs we get our music
from Spotify where it can be taken down
and it gets even more complicated when
these differ
platforms start fighting with each other
over who has access to what back in
January Epic Games announced an
exclusivity deal with Metro Exodus just
two weeks before the game's launch after
many people had already pre-ordered it
on Steam sparking backlash from Steam
users who wanted their money back and
steam itself who wanted to sell the game
if you want to watch the marvelous
missus Mazal you needed Amazon Prime
subscription if you want to watch
stranger things you'll need a Netflix
subscription if you want to watch Star
Trek discovery well hopefully you can
borrow a CBS all access password from
your dad but the point is people are
shelling out money to all these
platforms for temporary access to a TV
show instead of buying a box set
remember when you just had to choose
between DVD and blu-ray while it's
annoying to have 37 different logins and
frustrating to use up hard drive space
for some dumb software you only need for
one game there are pretty serious
ramifications to these new ownership
models last year farmers lost the right
to repair tractors and equipment they
bought from John Deere under a new
agreement farmers can no longer access
or modify the source code of any farm
equipment software or change engine
settings they can't even purchase repair
parts without going through an
authorized dealer which you can find
through their app this is a big deal for
farmers who have been modifying and
fixing their own equipment since forever
if an important piece of farm equipment
breaks they can't always afford to wait
for a John Deere rep to come update
their software for them and not being
allowed to upgrade their tractors means
they can't update their systems to meet
future emissions requirements which
means when standards change they'll have
to buy a new tractor this isn't new it's
just spreading without software our
smartphones which have become pretty
indispensable are just fancy boxes we
lease that software leasing software
isn't anything new either as Microsoft
pushes office 365 subscriptions or Adobe
doing basically the same thing and we're
at a point where we're literally
advocating for laws so that we can fix
things that we already own the right to
repair movement has already been picking
up steam and appealing to the US
government to address these issues so as
big companies like Apple and Google and
Disney take over platforms and by
everyone out we might finally have fewer
passwords to memorize and fewer apps to
purchase but at what cost
to put it bluntly the cost is our data
according to Cernik data have become
increasingly central to firms and their
relations with workers customers and
other capitalists platforms became an
efficient way to monopolize extract
analyze and use the increasingly large
amounts of data that we're being
recorded so while some of these
businesses operate by skimming off the
top of sales or charging subscription
fees a portion of their money and
success actually comes from collecting
it using and selling your information
and these platforms are being
increasingly integrated into our daily
lives
uber calculates fares based on
information coming in through the app
Spotify recommends new music based on an
analysis of what you've been listening
to and then there are companies who are
flat-out selling information for profit
to third-party data brokers who
forwarded on to ad agencies insurance
brokers and anyone else who wants it
kind of like how rockefeller owned all
the oil big tech companies monopolizing
on data are starting to take over
sections of the economy providing
valuable services that people won't stop
paying for and making it difficult for
anyone else to provide those services
what's different is instead of
controlling of physical resources these
businesses control our information and
how it's used Netflix has so much
information on people's viewing habits
they can keep recommending shows for
people to watch so they'll keep their
subscriptions active so it goes beyond
selling your search history to
advertisers companies use data to wield
a huge amount of power when it comes to
shaping our consumption or even the
economy as a whole
take google stadia an article from Brian
Feldman in the Intelligencer points out
that linking stadia so closely with
YouTube might create a feedback loop of
engagement metrics that could ultimately
influence game design choices according
to Feldman it's not hard to imagine a
world in which the stadia platform ends
up wielding major indirect influence
over what types of things game
developers create and what youtubers
decide to stream with everyone chasing
trends some game developers might just
end up creating cookie cutter games that
all look the same we see it with videos
like how when one watched conspiracy
theory videos YouTube suggested for more
conspiracy videos
leading to an increase in noir
conspiracy content leading to more
conspiracy theorists who wanted more
conspiracy content they've since fixed
that but you're usually only one mukbang
video away from the topic dominating
your homepage but are we getting ahead
of ourselves more than a century ago
policy makers were confronted with a
very similar problem when people started
using telephones people owned their
telephones but they didn't own the
system they were using to communicate as
people began to rely on telephones for
communication phone companies turned
into big unregulated monopolies so the
government started placing restrictions
on the companies to keep them from
exploiting consumers allowing them to be
monopolies but treating them as
utilities so maybe the Federal Trade
Commission will do something similar
with tech platforms some policy makers
even proposed creating new departments
and government to oversee big platforms
well it's still unclear what that will
look like with uber drivers striking to
unionize and Mark Zuckerberg testifying
before Congress it seems like calls for
intervention will only increase so what
do you think are we destined for lives
in the matrix where our data is
extracted so big companies can profit
trillions of dollars and dictate
everything we do with our time or will
we find a middle ground where we live
harmoniously with our platforms in some
kind of data-driven utopia let us know
what you think thanks to all our patrons
who support the channel and our podcasts
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and before you go I want to give
a final shout-out to our sponsor pinch
arrow watches bench arrow watches our
classy bold and have the look and feel
of luxury watches that are ten times the
price don't miss out on their fifth
anniversary sale where you can get a
discount on any of the watches on their
site take advantage of their anniversary
sale by getting up to 25% off your
entire order by clicking the link in the
description and as always thanks for
watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]